[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the ai
alignment podcast i'm lucas perry today
we have an episode with andres gomes
emilson and david pierce
on identity this episode is about
identity from the ontological
epistemological and phenomenological
perspectives
in less jargony language we discuss
identity
from the fundamental perspective of what
actually
exists of how identity arises given
functional world models and self-models
in biological organisms
and of the subjective or qualitative
experience of self or
identity as a feature of consciousness
given these angles on identity we
discuss what identity is
the formation of identity in biological
life
via evolution why identity is
important to explore and its ethical
implications
and implications for game theory
and we directly discuss its relevance to
the ai
alignment problem and the project of
creating beneficial ai
i think the question of how is this
relevant to ai
alignment to be a very useful one to
explore here
in the intro so i'll go ahead and do
that for
a little bit the ai alignment problem
can be construed
in the technical limited sense of the
question of how to program ai systems to
understand and be aligned with human
values
preferences goals ethics and objectives
in a limited sense this is strictly a
technical problem
that supervenes upon research in machine
learning
ai computer science psychology
neuroscience philosophy etc
i like to approach the problem of
aligning ai systems from a broader
and more generalist perspective so in
light of this
i do so through a broader view of ai
alignment that takes into account
the problems of ai governance
philosophy ai ethics and
it reflects on the context in which the
technical side of the problem will be
taking place
the motivations of humanity and the
human beings engaged in the ai alignment
process
the ingredients required for success and
other
civilization level questions on our way
hopefully
to beneficial super intelligence it is
from both of these perspectives that i
feel
exploring the question of identity is
important
ai researchers have their own identities
and those identities factor
into their lived experience of the world
their motivations
and their ethics in fact the same is of
course true
of policymakers and anyone in positions
of power
to influence the alignment process so
being aware of commonly held identity
models and views is important for
understanding their consequences and
functions in the world
as more and more powerful ai systems
begin to be developed and deployed
from a macroscopic perspective identity
has evolved over the past 4.5 billion
years on earth
and surely will continue to do so in
both ai systems themselves
and in the humans which hope to wield
that power
some humans may wish to merge with the
ai others may simply be content with
passing away
or death and other humans may wish to be
upgraded
or uploaded in some way questions of
identity are also
crucial to this process of relating to
one another
and to ai systems in a rapidly evolving
world
where what it means to be human is
quickly changing where
copies of digital minds or ais can be
made trivially
and the boundary between what we
conventionally call the self and the
world
begins to dissolve and break down in new
ways challenging
our commonly held intuitions and
demanding new understandings of
ourselves
and of identity in particular i also
want to highlight
an important thought from this podcast
that any actions we wish to take
with regards to improving or changing
understandings of
lived experience of identity must be
sociologically relevant
or such interventions simply risk being
irrelevant
this means understanding what is
reasonable for human beings to be able
to
update their minds with and accept over
certain periods of time
and also the gain theoretic implications
of certain views of identity
and their functions in society and
civilization this conversation is thus
an attempt to
broaden the discussion on these issues
outside of what is normally discussed
and to flag this area as something
worthy of further consideration
for those not familiar with david pierce
or andres gomes emilson
david is a co-founder of the world
transhumanist association
rebranded humanity plus and is a
prominent figure
within the transhumanism movement in
general you might know him from his work
on the hedonistic imperative
a book which explores our moral
obligation to work towards the
abolition of suffering and all sentient
life through technological intervention
andres is a consciousness researcher at
the qualia research institute
and is also the co-founder and president
of the stanford transhumanist
association
he has a masters in computational
psychology from stanford
the future of life institute is a
non-profit and this podcast is funded
and supported
by listeners like you so if you find
what we do on this podcast to be
important and beneficial
please consider supporting the podcast
by donating at futureoflife.org
donate if you'd like to be a regular
supporter please consider a monthly
subscription donation to
make sure that we can continue our
efforts into the future
these contributions make it possible for
us to bring you conversations like these
and to develop the podcast further you
can also follow us on your preferred
listening platform by searching for us
directly or following the links on the
page for this podcast found in the
description
and with that here's my conversation
with andres
gomes emilson and david pierce
so i just want to start off with some
quotes here that i think
would be useful so the last podcast that
we had was with you all noah hirari and
max tegmark
and one of the points that you've all
really emphasized was the importance of
self-understanding
questions like who am i what am i in the
age of technology
you've all said quote get to know
yourself better it's maybe the most
important thing in life
we haven't really progressed much in the
last thousands of years
and the reason is that yes we keep
getting this advice but we don't really
want to do it he goes on to say that
quote
especially as technology will give us
all at least some of us more and more
power
the temptations of naive utopias are
going to be more and more irresistible
and i think the really most powerful
check on these naive utopias is really
getting to know yourself better
so in search of getting to know
ourselves better i want to explore this
question
of identity with both of you so
to start off what is identity
one problem is that we have more than
one conception of identity there is the
strict
logical sense philosophers call the
indiscernibility of identicals if a
equals b then anything true of a is true
of b
one sense that's trivially true but when
it comes to something like
personal identity just doesn't hold
water at all
one is different person from your
namesake who went to bed last night
and it's very easy to shift between
these two different senses of identity
or or might speak of united states
in what sense is the united states the
same nation
in 2020 as it was in 1975
it's interest relative yeah and to go a
little bit deeper on that
i would make the distinction as david
made between ontological identity
like what fundamentally is actually
going on in the physical world in
instantiated reality but then there's
conventional identity
definitely the idea of continuing to
exist from one moment to another as a
human
and also countries and so on and then
there's also phenomenological
identity which is kind of our intuitive
common sense
view of what we are and basically
what are the conditions that will allow
us to continue to exist
we can go into more detail but yeah the
phenomenological
notion of identity is an incredible can
of worms
because there's so many different ways
of experiencing identity
and all of them have their own
interesting idiosyncrasies
most people tend to confuse the two that
tend to confuse ontological
and phenomenological identity and just
as a simple example that i'm sure we
will
revisit in the future when a person has
let's say a ego dissolution or a
mystical experience and they
feel that they merge with the rest of
the cosmos and they come out and say oh
we're all one consciousness
that tends to be interpreted as some
kind of
grasp of an ontological reality
whereas we could argue in a sense that
that was just a shift
in phenomenological identity that your
sense of self got transformed
not necessarily you're actually directly
merging with the cosmos in a literal
sense
although of course it might be very
indicative of
how conventional our sense of identity
is if it can be
modified so drastically in other states
of consciousness
right and so let's just start with the
ontological sense
how does one understand or think about
identity from the ontological side
in order to reason about this you need a
shared frame of reference for what
actually
exists and the nature of a number of
things including the nature of time and
space
and memory because in the common sense
view of time called presentism
where basically there's just the present
moment the past
is a convenient construction and the
future is the fiction
useful in practical sense but they don't
literally exist
in that sense this notion that a equals
b
in the sense of like hey you could
modify what happens to a and that will
automatically also modify what happens
to b
kind of makes sense and you can perhaps
think of identity as moving over time
along with everything else on the other
hand if you have a
eternalist point of view where basically
you
interpret the whole of space-time as
just basically there
in their own coordinates in the
multiverse that kind of provides a
different notion of ontological
identity because each in a sense moment
of experience
is its own separate piece of reality
in addition you also need to consider
the question of connectivity like in
what way different parts of reality are
connected to each other and in a
conventional sense
as you go from one second to the next
you continue to be
connected to yourself in an unbroken
stream of consciousness and this
has actually led some philosophers to
hypothesize that
the proper unit of identity is from the
moment in which you wake up to the
moment in which you go to sleep because
that's an
unbroken chain of stream of
consciousness but from a
scientific and philosophically rigorous
point of view
it's actually difficult to make the case
that
our stream of consciousness is truly
unbroken and
definitely if you have a eternalist
point of view
on experience and on the nature of time
what you will instead see is from the
moment you wake up to the moment you go
to sleep
there's actually been an extraordinarily
large amount of
snapshots of discrete moments of
experience
and in that sense each of those
individual moment of experiences
would be its own ontologically separate
individual now one of the things that
become kind of complicated with a kind
of an eternalist
account of time and identity is that you
cannot actually
change it there's nothing you can
actually do to a so like that reasoning
of if you do anything to a
and a equals b then the same will happen
to b doesn't
even actually apply in here because
everything is already there you cannot
actually modify a
anymore that you can modify the number
five yes it's a rather depressing
perspective
in many ways the eternalist feud if one
internalizes it too much it can lead to
a sense of fatalism and despair
a lot of the time it's probably actually
best to think of the future as open
okay so this helps to clarify some of
the ontological part of identity
now you mentioned this phenomenological
aspect
and i want to say also the
epistemological
aspect of identity could you unpack
those two
and maybe clarify this distinction for
me if you wouldn't parse it this way but
i guess i would say that the
epistemological
one is the models that human beings have
about the world
and about ourselves it includes how the
world is populated with a lot of
different objects that have identity
like
humans and planets and galaxies and then
we have our self model
which is the model of our body and
our space and social groups and who we
think we are and then there's the
phenomenological
identity which is that subjective
qualitative experience of self or the
ego
in relation to experience or where
there's an identification with attention
and experience
so could you unpack these two later
senses yeah for sure
so i mean in a sense you could have like
an implicit self model
that doesn't actually become part of
your consciousness or it's
not necessarily something that you're
explicitly rendering you know this goes
on all the time i mean you've definitely
i'm sure i had the experience of riding
a bicycle and after a little while you
can kind of like almost do it without
thinking of course
you're engaging with the process in a
very embodied fashion but you're not
cognizing very much about it and
definitely you're not representing let's
say your body state or you're
representing
exactly what is going on in a cognitive
way it's all kind of implicit
in the way in which you feel and i would
say that paints a little bit of a
distinction between
a self model which is ultimately
functional
it has to do with are you processing the
information
that you require to solve the task that
involves modeling
what you are in your environment and
distinguishing it from
the felt sense of are you a person
where are you how are you located and so
on
the first one is the one that most of
robotics and machine learning
that have like an embodied component are
really trying to get at
you just need the appropriate
information processing in order to solve
the task
they're not very concerned about does
this feel like anything or does it feel
like a particular
entity or a self to be that particular
algorithm
whereas yeah we're talking about the
phenomenological sense of identity then
yeah that's like very explicitly about
how it feels like and there's all kinds
of ways in which
a healthy so to speak sense of identity
can be broken down in all sorts of
interesting
ways there's many failure modes we can
put it that way
one might argue i mean i suspect for
example david pierce might say this
which is that our self models are our
implicit sense of self
because of the way in which it was
brought up through darwinian selection
pressures
it's already extremely ill in some sense
at least from the point of view of
it actually telling us something true
and actually making us do something
ethical
it has all sorts of problems but it is
definitely
functional i mean you can anticipate
being a person tomorrow
and plan accordingly leave messages to
yourself by encoding them in memory
and yeah this convenient sense of
conventional identity
is very natural for most people's
experiences
i can briefly mention a couple ways in
which it can break down
one of them is deep personalization it's
a particular psychological disorder
where one stops feeling like a person
and it might have something to do with
basically not being able to synchronize
with your bodily feelings
in such a way that you don't actually
feel embodied you may feel kind of a
disincarnate entity
or just a witness experiencing a human
experience but not actually being that
person
then you also have things such as a
pathogen
induced sense of shared identity with
others if you take
mdma you may feel that all of humanity
is deeply connected or we're all
part of the same essence of humanity
in a very positive sense of identity but
perhaps not in a
evolutionary adaptive sense finally is
people with a multiple personality
disorder
where in a sense they have like a very
unstable sense of who they are
and sometimes it can be so extreme that
there's kind of epistemological
blockages
from one sense of self to another as
new scientist donald hoffman likes to
say fitness
trumps truth each of us runs a world
simulation but
it's not an impartial accurate faithful
world simulation
i am at the center of a world simulation
the david pearson-centric world
simulation
i'm the guy the hub of reality that
follows me around
and of course there are billions upon
billions of other
analogous examples too now this is
genetically
extremely fitness enhancing but it's
systematically
misleading in that sense i think
darwinian life is
so wrapping up here on these different
aspects of identity i just want to make
sure that i have all of them here
would you say that those are all the
aspects one could have this distinction
between
type and token identity and that it be
possible
let's say from scratch to create
a molecular duplicate of you is that
person you
it's type identical but it's not token
identical
oh right so i think i've heard this used
in some other places as numerical
distinction versus
qualitative distinction is that right
yeah that's the
same distinction yeah so unpacking here
more about what
identity is let's talk about it purely
as something that the world has produced
so what can we say about the evolution
of identity
and biological life what is the efficacy
of
certain identity models in darwinian
evolution
i would say that self models most likely
have existed potentially since
pretty early on in the evolutionary
timeline
you may argue that in some sense even
the bacteria has like some
kind of self model but again a self
model is really just functional
the bacteria does need to know at least
implicitly its size in order to be able
to navigate
its environment follow chemical
gradients and so on
not step on itself but that's not the
same again as
a phenomenal sense of identity and that
one
i would strongly suspect came much later
perhaps with the advent of the first
primitive nervous systems
that would be only if actually running
that phenomenal model is giving you some
kind of fitness advantage
one of the things that you will
encounter with david and i is that we
think
that phenomenally bound experiences have
a lot of
computational properties and in a sense
the reason why we're conscious has to do
with the fact that
unified moments of experience are doing
computationally
useful leg work it comes when you
merge implicit self models in just the
functional sense
together with the computational benefits
of actually running a conscious system
that perhaps for the first time in
history you will
actually have a phenomenal self model
now i would suspect probably in the
cambrian explosion this was already
going on to some extent
all of these interesting evolutionary
oddities that happen in the cameron
explosion
probably had like some kind of
rudimentary sense of self
i would be skeptical that is going on
for example in plants
one of the the key reasons is that
running
a real-time world simulation
in a conscious framework is very
calorically expensive yes
it's the scandal what evolutionarily
speaking is
consciousness for i mean what can a
p zombie not do the perspective that
andres and i are
articulating is that essentially what
makes biological minds
special is phenomenal binding the
capacity
to run real-time phenomenally bound
world simulations i.e not just to be 86
billion discrete membrane-bound pixels
of experience
but somehow an entire cross-modally
matched real-time world simulation
made up of individual objects
somehow bound into a unitary self the
unity of perception
is extraordinarily computationally
powerful
and adaptive now simply saying that it's
extremely fitness enhancing doesn't
explain it because
something like telepathy would be
extremely fitness enhancing too but it's
physically impossible
but yes how biological minds actually
managed to run
for normally bound world simulations is
unknown it would seem to be classically
impossible
one way to appreciate just how
advantageous non-psychotic phenomenal
binding
is is to look at syndromes where it even
partially breaks down
simultaneognosia where one can only see
one object at once or motion blindness
they can autopsy it where
you can't actually see moving objects or
florid schizophrenia now just imagine
those syndromes
combined why aren't we just micro
experiential zombies
do we have any interesting points here
to look at in the evolutionary tree for
where
identity is substantially different from
a consciousness like if we look back at
human
evolution it seems that it's given the
apes and particularly our species
a pretty strong sense of self and that
gives rise to much of our
ape socialization and politics so i'm
wondering if there's anything else like
maybe insects or other creatures that
have gone a different
direction and also if you guys might be
able to speak a little bit on
the formation of ape identity
definitely i think like the perspective
of the selfish gene
is pretty illuminating here nominally
our sense of identity
is kind of the sense of one person one
mind
in practice however if you make sense of
identity
as well in terms of that which you want
to defend
or that which you consider worth
preserving you will see that people's
sense of identity also
extends to their family members
and of course you know with a neocortex
and ability to
create more complex associations then
you have crazy things like
sense of identity being based on race or
country of origin or other you know
constructs like that that
are building on top of imports from the
sense of hey the people who are familiar
to you
feel more like you it's genetically
adaptive
to have that and and from the point of
view of the selfish gene genes
that could recognize themselves in
others
and favor the existence of others that
also share the same genes
are more likely to reproduce and that's
called inclusive fitness
in biology that you're not just trying
to survive yourself or make copies of
yourself you're also trying to help
those that are very similar to you
do the same almost certainly it's a
huge aspect of how we perceive the world
just anecdotally from a number of trip
reports there's like this
interesting thread of how some chemicals
like mdma
and 2cb for those who don't know it's
kind of this
pathogenic psychedelic that people get
the strange
sense that people they've never met
before in their life
are as close to them as a cousin or
maybe a
half brother half sister and it's a very
comfortable and
quite beautiful feeling and you could
imagine that
nature was very selective on who
do you give that feeling to in order to
maximize inclusive fitness
all of these builds up to the overall
prediction i would make
that the sense of identity of ants and
other
extremely social insects might be very
different
the reason being that they are
genetically incentivized to basically
treat each other as themselves most ants
themselves don't produce any offspring
they are
genetically sisters and all of their
genetic incentives
are into basically helping the queen
pass on the genes into
other colonies and in that sense i would
imagine an
ant probably sees other ants of the same
colony
pretty much as themselves
yes there's extraordinary finding a few
years ago of
members of one species of social ant
actually
passed the mirror test which has
traditionally been regarded as the gold
standard
of concept of a self and it was shocking
enough to many people
when a small fish was shown to be
capable of
mirror self-recognition if ants
can pass the mirror test it suggests
some form of metacognition
self-recognition is extraordinarily
ancient
so what is it that distinguishes humans
from non-human animals
i suspect it's relating to something
which
is still physically unexplained how is
it
that a massively parallel brain
gives rise to serial logical linguistic
thought unexplained but i would say that
is what distinguishes us most of all not
a possession of a self concept
so is there such a thing as a right
answer to questions of identity
or is it fundamentally just something
that's functional
or is it ultimately arbitrary i think
there is a right answer
from a functional perspective there's
just so many different ways of thinking
about it
and i mean as i was describing perhaps
with ants
and humans their sense of identity is
probably pretty different but you know
they
both are useful for passing on the genes
so in that sense they they're all
equally valid
imagine in the future some kind of a
swarm mind
that also has its own distinct
functionally adaptive
sense of identity and i mean in that
sense yeah there's no ground truth
to what it should be from the point of
view of functionality it really just
depends on what is the replication unit
ontologically though i think there is a
case to be made that
either open or empty individualism are
true
maybe it would be good to define those
terms first
before we do that your answer then is
just that yes you you suspect that also
ontologically in terms of fundamental
physics there are answers to questions
of identity like identity itself isn't
a confused category yeah i don't think
it's uh leaky
raiffication as they say and then like
from the phenomenological sense
is the self an illusion or not is the
self a valid category
is your view also on identity that there
is a right answer there
from the phenomenological point of view
no i would consider it a parameter
mostly just something you can provide
and there's trade-offs for different
experiences of identity
okay how about you david i think
ultimately yes
there are right answers but in practice
life would be unlivable if we didn't
maintain these fictions
these fictions in one sense are deeply
immoral just let's say one punishes
someone
for a deed that their namesake performed
10
15 20 years ago i mean america executed
a murderer for
a crime that was done 20 years ago now
quite aside from issues of freedom and
responsibility and so on this is just uh
scapegoating so david you feel that in
the ontological sense there are
right or wrong answers to questions of
identity and
in the phenomenological sense and in the
functional sense
yes okay so then i guess you disagree
with andres about the phenomenological
sense
i'm not sure i'm just i agree about most
things
[Laughter]
are we disagreeing andreas i'm not sure
i mean what i said about the
phenomenal aspect of identity was that i
think of it as a parameter
of our world simulation and in that
sense there's kind of no
true phenomenological sense of identity
they're all
useful for different things the reason i
would say this too is that okay even if
you assume that something like each
snapshot of experience is its own
separate identity
i'm not even sure you can accurately
represent that
in a moment of experience itself this is
itself a huge can of worms it opens up
the problem of
reference can we even actually refer to
something
from our own vintage point of view my
intuition here
is that whatever sense of identity you
have at a phenomenal
level i think of it as a parameter of
the world simulation and i don't think
it can
be an accurate representation of
something true it's just going to be a
feeling
so to speak i could endorse that
we fundamentally misperceive each other
and the hogan sisters craniophagus
twins know something that the rest of us
don't
and that the hogan sisters share a
thalmic
bridge which enables them partially into
a limited extent
to mind-meld the rest of us can see
each other as essentially yes people or
objects that have feelings
and when one thinks of one's ignorance
on the whole one might be
lamenting one's failures as a
mathematician
or a physicist or anything else but an
absolutely fundamental form of ignorance
that we take for granted
is that other people other non-human
animals
essentially objects with feelings
whereas we
individually have first-person
experience
whether it's going to be possible to
overcome this in future i think it's
going to be
immensely technically challenging
building something like reversible
family bridges a lot depends on one's
theory of phenomenal binding but let's
pretend
a future civilization in which partial
mind
building is routine i think it will lead
to
a revolution not just in morality but in
decision
theoretic rationality too and that
yeah one will take in account of let's
say the desires the interests and the
preferences
of what will seem different aspects of
oneself
so why does identity matter morally i
think you guys have made a good case
about how it's
important functionally historically in
terms of biological evolution
and then in terms of like society and
culture identity is clearly
extremely important for human social
relations
for navigating social hierarchies and
understanding one's position
of having a concept of self and identity
over time
but why does it matter morally here
one interesting story where you can
think of a lot of social movements
and in a sense a lot of ideologies that
have existed in human history
as attempts to hack people's sense of
identities
or make use of them for the purpose of
the reproduction of the ideology or the
social movement
itself to a large extent a lot of the
the things that you see in uh therapy
have a lot to do with
expanding your sense of identity to
include your future self
as well which is something that a lot of
people struggle with when it comes to
impulsive decisions or irrationality
there's this interesting point of view
of how a two-year-old or a
three-year-old hasn't yet
internalized the fact that they will
wake up tomorrow and that the
consequences of what they did today
will linger on in the following days
just kind of like a revelation
when a kid finally internalizes the fact
that oh my gosh like i will continue to
exist
for the rest of my life there's gonna be
a point where i'm gonna be
40 years old and also there's going to
be a time where i'm 80 years old and
like all of those
are real and i should plan ahead for it
ultimately i do think that advocating
for a
very inclusive sense of identity where
the locus of identity is consciousness
itself
i do think that might be a tremendous
moral and ethical implications
we want a sense of us that embraces all
sentient beings i think
which is extremely ambitious but that i
think should be the long-term goal
right so there's a spectrum here and
where you fall on the spectrum
will lead to different functions and
behaviors solipsism
or like extreme egoism on one end
pure selflessness or ego death or pure
altruism
on the other end and perhaps there are
other degrees
and axes on which you can move but the
point is
it leads to radically different
identifications and relations with
other sentient beings and with other
instantiations of consciousness
would our conception of death be
different if
it was convention to give someone a
different name when they woke up
each morning and because after all it is
akin to reincarnation
why isn't it that when one is drifting
asleep
each night one isn't afraid of death
it's because in some sense one believes
one's going to be reincarnated in the
morning
i like that okay so i want to return to
this question after we hit on
the different views of identity to
really unpack the different ethical
implications more but i wanted to
sneak that in here for a bit of context
so pivoting back to
this sort of historical and contextual
analysis of
identity we talked about biological
evolution
as like instantiating these things how
do you guys view
religion as codifying
an egoist view on identity
religion codifies the idea of the
eternal soul
and the soul kind of i think maps very
strongly onto the phenomenological self
it makes that the thing that is
immutable
or undying or which transcends this
realm i'm talking obviously specifically
here about abrahamic religions
but then also in buddhism there is the
self is an illusion
or what david referred to as empty
individualism which we'll get into
where it says that that identification
with a phenomenological self
is fundamentally a misapprehension of
reality and like a confusion
and that that leads to attachment and
suffering and fear of death so do you
guys
have comments here about religion as
codifying views on identity
i mean i think it's definitely really
interesting that there are different
views
of identity in religion how i grew up i
always assumed
religion was about souls and getting
into heaven
but yeah i mean it turns out i i just
didn't know about eastern religions
and cults that also happen to sometimes
have like different views of personal
identity
i mean that was definitely a revelation
to me i would
actually say that i started questioning
the sense of a common sense
of personal identity before i learned
about eastern religions
and i was really pretty surprised and
very happy when i found out that let's
say hinduism
actually has a kind of universal
consciousness take on identity
a socially sanctioned way of looking at
the world
that has a very expansive sense of
identity
buddhism is also pretty interesting
because as far as i understand it
they consider actually pretty much any
view of identity to be
cause for suffering fundamentally has to
do with a sense of craving either for
existence
or craving for non-existence which they
also consider a problem
a buddhist would generally say that even
something like universal consciousness
you know believing that we're all
fundamentally krishna incarnating in
many different ways
itself will also be a source of
suffering
to some extent because you may kind of
crave further existence which may not be
very good from their point of view it
makes me optimistic that there's like
other types of religions with other
views of identity
yes so one of my earliest memories that
my mother belonged to order of the cross
who worshiped father mother very obscure
small vaguely christian denomination
non-sexist
and i recall being told age five that i
could be born again
might be his little boy but it might be
his little girl because
gender didn't matter and i was
absolutely appalled at this the age of
five or whatnot uh because yeah in some
sense
girls were that i couldn't actually
express this defective
and religious conceptions of identity
vary immensely i mean one thinks of
something like
original sin in christianity so yeah i
mean i could make a lot of
superficial comments about religion but
one would need to actually
explore in detail the different
religious traditions and their differing
conceptions of identity
what are the different views on identity
if you can't say anything why don't you
hit on the ontological sense
and the phenomenological sense or if we
just want to stick to the
phenomenological sense then we can
i mean are you talking about uh open
empty closed yeah
so that would be the phenomenological
sense yeah no actually i would i would
claim
those are attempts at getting at the
ontological sense
okay if you do truly have a soul
ontology something that implicitly a
very large percentage of the
human population have that would be yeah
in this view called a
closed individualist perspective common
sense you start existing when you're
born you stop existing when you die
you're just a stream of consciousness
even perhaps more strongly you're a soul
that has experiences
but experiences maybe are not
fundamental to what you are
then there is the more buddhist and
definitely more
generally scientifically minded view
which is empty
individualism which is that you only
exist as a moment of experience
and from one moment to the next you're a
completely different entity
and then finally there is open
individualism
which is like hinduism claiming that we
are
all one consciousness fundamentally
there is a ontological way of thinking
of these notions of identity
it's possible that a lot of people think
of them just phenomenologically
or they may just think like there's no
further fact beyond the phenomenal
in which case something like closed
individualism
for most people most of the time is
self-evidently true
because you are kind of moving in time
and you can notice
that you continue to be yourself from
one moment to the next
then of course what would it feel like
if you weren't the same person from one
moment to the next
well each of those moments might
completely
be under the illusion that it is a
continuous self
for most things in philosophy and
science if you want to use something as
evidence
it has to agree with one theory and
disagree with another one and the sense
of continuity from one second to the
next
seems to be compatible with all three
views so it's it's not itself
much much evidence either way states of
depersonalization are probably much more
akin to empty individualism from a
phenomenological point of view and then
you have ego death
and definitely some experiences of the
psychedelic variety
especially high doses psychedelics tend
to produce very strong feelings of open
individualism
that often comes in the form of noticing
that your
conventional sense of self is very buggy
and doesn't seem to track anything real
but then realizing that you can identify
with awareness
itself and if you do that then in some
sense automatically you realize that you
are
every other experience out there since
the fundamental ingredient of a weakness
or awareness is shared with every
conscious experience
these views on identity are confusing to
me because
agents haven't existed for most of the
universe
and i don't know why we need to
privilege agents and our
ideas of identity they seem to me just
emergent patterns
of the big ancient old physical universe
process that's unfolding
it's confusing to me that just because
there are complex
self and world modeling patterns in the
world that we need to privilege them
with some kind of shared identity across
themselves or across the world
do you see what i mean here oh yeah yeah
definitely i'm not a agent
centric and i mean in a sense like also
like all of these other
exotic feelings of identity often also
come
with states of low agency you actually
don't feel that you have much of a
choice
in what you could do i mean definitely
depersonalization for example
often comes with a sense of inability to
make choices
that actually you it's not you who's
making the choice they're just unfolding
and happening
of course in some meditative traditions
that's considered a path to awakening
but
in practice for a lot of people that's a
very unpleasant type of experience
it sounds like i might be privileging
agents i would say
that's not the case if you kind of zoom
out and you see the
bigger world view it includes basically
this
concept david calls it non-materialist
physicalist
idealism where the laws of physics
describe
the behavior of the universe but that
which is behaving
according to the laws of physics is
qualia is consciousness itself
i take very seriously the idea that a
given molecule
or a particular atom contains moments of
experience
it's just perhaps very fleeting and very
dim or just not very relevant in many
ways but i i do think it's there
and sense of identity maybe not in a
phenomenal sense i don't think an atom
actually
feels like an agent over time but
continuity of its experience and the
boundaries of his experience
would have strong bearings on
ontological
sense of identity there's a huge
obviously a huge jump
between talking about the identity of
atoms and then talking about the
identity of a moment of experience
which presumably is an emergent effect
of 100 billion
neurons themselves made of so many
different atoms
crazy as it may be it is both david
pierce's view and my view
that actually each moment of experience
does
stand as an ontological unit it's just
an
ontological unit of a certain kind that
usually we don't see in physics but it
is
both physical and ontologically closed
maybe you could unpack this you know
myriological nihilism
maybe i privilege this view where i just
am trying to be as simple as possible
and not build up too many concepts on
top of each other
meteorological nihilism basically says
that there are
no entities that have parts everything
is
part-less all that exists in reality is
individual monets so to speak things
that are like fundamentally
self-existing
but that if you have let's say monad a
and monad b
just put together side by side that
doesn't entail
that now there is a monet a b that kind
of
mixes a two or if you put a bunch of
fundamental quarks together that it
makes something called an atom
you would just say that it's quarks
arranged atom-wise
there's the structure and the
information there but it's just made of
the monads
right and the atom is a wonderful case
basically the same as a molecule where i
would say
meteorological nihilism with fundamental
particles as
just the only truly existing beings does
seem to be false when you look at how
for example molecules behave the
building block
account of how chemical bonds happen
which is kind of with these
leos diagrams of how can have a single
bond or double bond and you have the
octet rule and
you're trying to build these chains of
atoms strung together
and all that matters for those diagrams
is what each atom is locally connected
to
however if you just use these in order
to predict what molecules are possible
and how they behave
and their properties you will see that
there's a lot of artifacts
that are empirically disproven and
over the years chemistry has become more
and more sophisticated
where eventually it's come to the
realization that you need to take into
account
the entire molecule at once in order to
understand what it's
quote unquote dynamically stable
configuration which involves
all of the electrons and all of the
nuclei simultaneously
interlocking into a particular pattern
that self-replicates and it has new
properties over and above
the parts exactly that doesn't make any
sense to me or my intuition so maybe my
intuitions are just really wrong
where does the new property or causality
come from because it essentially has
causal efficacy over and above the parts
yeah it's tremendously confusing i mean
i'm currently writing an article about
basically how this sense of topological
segmentation
can in a sense account both for this
effect of
what we might call weak downward
causation which
is like you get a molecule and now the
molecule will
have effects in the world that you need
to take into account
all of the electrons and all of the
nuclei simultaneously as a unit
in order to actually know what the
effect is going to be in the world
you cannot just take each of the
components uh separately
that's something that we could call as
weak downward conversation it's not that
fundamentally you're introducing a new
law of physics
everything is still predicted by the
schrodinger equation
it's still governing the behavior of the
entire molecule
it's just that the appropriate unit of
analysis is not
the electron but it would be the entire
molecule
now if you pair this together with
a sense of identity that comes from
topology
then i think there might be a good case
for why
moments of experience are discrete
entities
the analogy here with topological
segmentation hopefully i'm not gonna
lose too many listeners here but we can
make an analogy with for example a
balloon that if you start out imagining
that you
are the surface of the balloon and then
you take the balloon by two ends and you
twist them in opposite directions
eventually at the middle point you get
what's called a pinch point
basically the balloon kind of collapses
in the center and you end up having
these
two smooth surfaces connected by a pinch
point
each of those twists creates a new
topological segment
or in a sense is like segmenting out the
balloon
you could basically interpret things
such as molecules
as new topological segmentations
of what's fundamentally the quantum
fields that is implementing them
usually the segmentations may look like
an electron or a proton but if you
assemble them together just right
you can get them to essentially melt
with each other and become
one topologically continuous unit the
nice thing about this
account is that you get everything that
you want you explain
on the one hand why identity would
actually have
causal implications and it's this weak
downward causation effect at the same
time as like being able to explain
how is it possible that the universe can
break down into many different entities
well the answer is the way in which is
breaking down is through
topological segmentations you end up
having this kind of
self-contained regions of the wave
function that
are discommunicated from the rest of it
and each of those might be a
different subject of experience it's
very much
an open question the intrinsic nature of
the physical
commonly materialism and physicalism are
equated but the point of view that
andreas and i
take seriously non-materialist physical
is actually
a form of idealism recently philosopher
phil goff galileo's error used to be
a skeptic critic of non-materialist
physicalism
because of the binding problem he's
recently published a book
defending it very much an open question
i mean we're making some background
assumptions here
uh critical background assumption is
physicalism
that quantum mechanics is complete there
is no element of reality that is missing
from
the equations or possibly the
fundamental equation
of physics but physics itself seems to
be
silent on the intrinsic nature of the
physical i mean intuitively
what is the nature of a quantum field
intuitively it's a field of insentience
but this isn't a scientific discovery
it's a very strong
philosophical intuition and if you
couple this with the fact that the only
part
of the world with which one has direct
access i.e one's own conscious mind
though this is controversial
is consciousness sentience the
non-materialist physicalist
will conjecture that we are typical in
one sense
that the fields of your central nervous
system aren't ontologically different
from the rest of the world
and what makes centurion beings special
is the way
that fields are organized into
subjects or experience egocentric world
simulations
now i'm personally fairly confident that
each of us individually is running
a minds negocentric world simulation
that direct realism is false
i'm not at all confident that i
certainly explore it
that experience is the intrinsic nature
of the physical the stuff of the world
but this is a tradition that goes back
via
russell ultimately to schopenhauer
schuberth essentially turning
kant on his head kant famously said that
all we will ever know
is phenomenology appearances we will
never
never know the intrinsic numeral nature
of the world
but schopenhauer argues that essentially
we do actually know one tiny piece of
the numeral essence of the world the
essence of the physical
and it's experiential so
yes tentatively at any rate andreas and
i would uh defend
non-materialist or idealistic
physicalism
the actual term number theories
physicalism is due to the late growth of
maxwell
sorry could you just define that real
quick i think we haven't physicalism
is the idea that no element of reality
is missing from the equations of physics
presumably some
relativistic generalization of the
schrodinger equation
it's a kind of naturalism too oh yes it
is naturalism there are some forms of
idealism and psychism that are
non-naturalistic
but this is uncompromisingly monist
non-materialist physicalism isn't
claiming that
primitive experiences is attached in
some way to fundamental physical
properties
the idea is that the actual intrinsic
nature of the essence of the physical
is experiential stephen hawking for
instance was
a wave function monis a doctrinaire
materialist but he famously said that we
have no idea what
breathes far into the equations and
makes there a universe
for us to describe now intuitively of
course
one assumes that the fire in the
equations
can't numeral essence of the world is
non-experiential but if so we have the
hard problem we have the binding problem
we have the problem of causal efficacy
a great mess of problems but if
and it's obviously a huge if the actual
intrinsic nature of the physical
is experiential then we have a theory of
reality
that is empirically adequate that has
tremendous
explanatory predictive power
mind-bogglingly implausible at least to
those of us
steeped in the conceptual framework of
materialism
but yes by transposing the entire
mathematical apparatus of modern physics
quantum field theory or its
generalization onto an idealist ontology
one actually has a complete account
of reality that explains the kind of the
technological successes
of science its predictive power and
doesn't give rise to such insoluble
mysteries as the hard problem i i think
all this is like very clarifying that
there are also
background metaphysical views which
people may or may not disagree upon
which are also important for identity i
also want to be careful to define some
terms
in case some listeners don't know what
they mean i think you hit on like four
different things which all had to do
with
consciousness the hard problem is why
different kinds of computation actually
why it's something to be that
computation or like why there's
consciousness correlated or associated
with that experience
then you also said the binding problem
is the binding problem
why there is a unitary experience that
you said modally connected earlier
yes and if one takes the standard view
from neuroscience
that your brain consists of 86 billion
odd discrete
decohered membrane-bound cells
then phenomenal binding either local or
global ought to be impossible
so yeah this is the binding problem this
partial structural mismatch that
neuroscience can apparently
if it scans your brain when you're
seeing a particular perceptual object
can pick out distributed feature
processors
edge detectors motion detectors color
mediating neurons
and yet there isn't the perfect
structural match that must exist if
physicalism is true
and david chalmers from this partial
structural
mismatch goes on to argue that dualism
must be true though i agree with david
chalmers
that yes phenomenal binding is
classically impossible
if one takes the intrinsic nature
argument seriously
then phenomenal unity is is minted in
the intrinsic nature argument recall is
that
experience or consciousness discloses
the intrinsic nature of the physical
now one of the reasons why this is so
desperately implausible is it makes the
fundamental
psychon of consciousness ludicrously
small
but there's a neglected corollary of
non-materialist physicalism
in that if experience discloses the
intrinsic nature of the physical
essentially experience must be
temporarily incredibly
fine grained and if you probe your
nervous system at a temporal resolution
or femtoseconds or eve in ato seconds
what would one find and it's my
guess that be possible to recover a
perfect
structural match between what you are
experiencing now
in your phenomenal world simulation and
the underlying physics
that superpositions or cat states are
individual entities now if the effective
lifetime of neuronal superpositions in
the cns were
milliseconds they would be the obvious
candidate for a perfect structural match
and to explain the phenomenal unity of
consciousness
but physicists not least max tegmark
have done the maths the
effective lifetime of neuronal
superpositions in the
cns assuming the unitarian dynamics is
femtoseconds or less which is
intuitively the reduction absurdum of
any kind of quantum mind
but one person's reduction absurdum is
another person's falsifiable prediction
and
i'm guessing i'm sounding like a
believer i'm not but i'm guessing
that when there is sufficiently
sensitive molecular matter wave
interferometry perhaps using
trained up mini brains that the
non-classical interference signature
will disclose perfect structural match
between what you're experiencing right
now you're in your unified world
simulation and the underlying physics
so we hit on the hard problem and also
the binding problem
there was like two other ones that you
threw out there earlier that i forgot
they were
yeah the problem of causal efficacy how
is it
that you and i can discuss
consciousness how is it that the raw
fields of consciousness
have not really the causal but also the
functional efficacy to inspire
discussions
of their existence and then what was the
last one
what's been called the palette problem p
a l
e double t e as in the fact that there
is
tremendous diversity of different kinds
of experience
and yet the fundamental entities
recognized by
physics at least on the normal tale uh
extremely
simple and homogeneous what explains
this extraordinarily rich
collective conscious experience
physics exhaustively describes the
structural relational properties of the
world
what physics doesn't do is deal in
essences
intrinsic nature now it's an extremely
plausible
assumption that the world's fundamental
fields
are non-experiential devoid of any
subjective properties and this may well
be the case
but if so we have a hard problem the
problem of course is efficacy
binding problem there's a whole raft of
problems
okay so this all serves the purpose of
codifying that there was these questions
up in the air about these metaphysical
views
which inform identity we got here
because we were talking about
meteorological nihilism
and andres said that one view that you
guys have
is that you can divide or cut up or
partition consciousness
into individual momentary
unitary moments of experience that you
claim are ontologically simple
what is your credence on this view
phenomenological evidence
when you experience your visual field
you don't only experience one point at a
time
the contents of your experience are not
ones and zeros
it isn't the case that you experience
one and then zero and then one again
rather you experience many different
types of qualia varieties
simultaneously visuals experience and
auditory experience and
and so on all of that gets presented to
you
i take that very seriously i mean some
other
researchers may fundamentally say that
that's an illusion that there's actually
never
a unified experience but i think that
has
way many more problems than actually
taking seriously the unity of
consciousness
a number of distinct questions here are
each of us
egocentric phenomenal world simulations
and a lot of people are implicitly
perceptual direct realists even though
they might disavow the label but
implicitly they assume that they have
some kind of direct access to physical
properties and they will
associate experience with some kind of
stream of
thoughts and feelings behind their
forehead
but then there is the question what is
the actual fundamental
nature of the world beyond your
phenomenal world simulation
is it experiential or non-experiential
i'm agnostic about that even though i
argue for non-materialist physicalism
so i guess i'm just trying to get a
better answer here
on how is it that we navigate these
views of identity towards
truth an example i thought of a
very big contrast between what you may
intuitively imagine is going on
versus what's actually happening is if
you're very afraid of snakes for example
and you you look at a snake you feel oh
my gosh it's
intruding into my world and i should get
away from it and you have kind of this
representation of it as a very big
author
you know anything that is very
threatening oftentimes you represent it
as an
other but crazily that's
actually just yourself to a large extent
because
it's still part of your experience you
know within your moment of experience
the whole phenomenal quality of looking
at a snake and thinking that's a other
is entirely contained within you in that
sense these ways of ascribing
identity and continuity to the things
around us or like a self-other division
are almost kind of psychotic they kind
of start out by assuming
that you can segment out a piece of your
experience and call it something
that belongs to somebody else even
though clearly is still just part of
your own experience it's you
but the background here is also that
you're calling your experience your own
experience which is maybe also a kind of
psychopathy is that the word you used
yeah yeah that's right
maybe the scientific thing is like
there's just snake experience
and it's neither yours nor not yours and
there's what we conventionally call a
snake
that said there are ways in which i
think you can use experience
to gain insight about other experiences
if you're looking at a
picture that has two blue
dots i think you can accurately say by
paying attention to one of those blue
dots the phenomenal property of
my sensation of blue is also in that
other part of my visual field
and this is a case where in a sense you
can i think meaningfully refer
to some aspect of your experience by
pointing at another aspect
of your experience it's still maybe in
some sense kind of crazy but it's still
closer to truth than many other things
that we think of or imagine
honest and true statements about the
nature of other people's experiences
i think are very much achievable
bridging the reference
gap i think might be possible to
overcome and you can probably aim for
like a true
sense of identity harmonizing the
phenomenal and the ontological
sense of identity i mean i think that
part of the motivation
for example in buddhism is that you need
to always be understanding yourself
in reality as it is or else you will
suffer and that it is through
understanding how things are that you'll
stop suffering
i like this point that you said about
unifying the
phenomenal identity and phenomenal self
with what is ontologically true
but that also seems not intrinsically
necessary because there's also this
other point here where
you can like maybe function or have the
epistemology
of any arbitrary identity view
but not identify with it you don't take
it as your ultimate
understanding of the nature of the world
or like what it means to be
this limited pattern in a giant system
i mean generally speaking that's
obviously a pretty good advice
it does seem to be something that's kind
of constrained to the workings of the
human mind
as it is currently implemented you know
i mean definitely
all these buddhist advices so don't
identify with it or don't get attached
to it
ultimately it cashes out in experiencing
less
of a craving for example or feeling less
despair
in some cases useful advice not
universally applicable
for many people their problem might be
something like sure like desire
craving attachment in which case you
know these buddhist
practices will actually be very helpful
but if your problem is
something like a melancholic depression
then lack of desire
doesn't actually seem very appealing
that is the default state and it's not a
good one
and be mindful of universalizing this
advice
yes other things being equal the
happiest people tend to have the most
desires of course
uh tremendous desire can also bring
tremendous suffering but there are very
large number of people in the world who
are essentially
unmotivated nothing really excites them
in some cases they're just waiting to
die melancholic depression desire can be
harnessed
big problem of course is that in the
darwinian world
many of our desires are mutually
inconsistent and to use
what to me at least would be a trivial
example not to everyone
if you have 50 different football teams
with all their supporters there is
simply
logically no way that the preferences of
these
fanatical football supporters can be
reconciled
but nonetheless by raising hedonic set
points one can
allow all football supporters to enjoy
gradients
of information sensitive bliss but there
is yeah simply no way to reconcile their
preferences
there's part of me that does want to do
some universalization here and like
maybe that is wrong
or unskillful to do but i seem to be
able to imagine a future
where say we get a line super
intelligence and there's some kind of
rapid expansion
some kind of optimization bubble of some
kind and
maybe there are like the worker ai's and
then there are like the exploiter ais
and the exploiter ais just get blissed
out and
imagine if some of the exploiter ais are
egomaniacs
in their hedonistic simulations and some
of them are hive minds and they all have
different views on open
individualism or closed individualism
some of the views on identity just seem
more deluded to me than others
i seem to have a problem with a
self-identification
and reification of self as something
it seems to me to take something that is
conventional and make it an ultimate
truth
which is confusing to the agent and that
to me seems bad or wrong like your world
model is wrong
part of me wants to say it is always
better to know the truth
but i also feel like i'm having a hard
time being able
to say how to navigate views of identity
in a true way
and then another part of me feels like
actually it doesn't really matter
only insofar as it affects the flavor of
that consciousness
if we find like the chemical or genetic
levers
for different notions of identity we
could presumably imagine a lot of
different
ecosystems of approaches to identity
in the future some of them perhaps being
much more adaptive than others
i do think i grasp a little bit like
maybe the intuition pump and i think
that's actually something that resonates
quite a bit with us which is that it is
an instrumental value for sure
to always be truth-seeking especially
when you're talking about like general
intelligence
it's very weird and it sounds like it's
going to fail
if you say hey i'm going to be
truth-seeking in every domain
except on here and these might be
identity or
value function or your model of physics
or something like that
but perhaps actual super intelligence in
some sense
it really entails having an open-ended
model for everything
including ultimately who you are
if you're not having those open-ended
models that can be revised with further
evidence and reasoning
you are not a super intelligence that
intuition pump may suggest that if
intelligence turns out to be extremely
adaptive and powerful
then presumably you know the super
intelligences of the future
will have like true models of what's
actually going on in the world
not just convenient fictions
yes in some sense i think uh i would
hope our long-term goal
is ignorance of the entire darwinian era
and its
horrors but it would be extremely
dangerous if we were to
give up prematurely we need to
understand
reality and the theoretical upper bounds
of
rational moral agency in the cosmos and
ultimately when we have
done literally everything that it is
possible to do to
minimize and prevent suffering i think
in some sense we want to forget about it
altogether but i would stress the risks
of
premature defeatism of course we're
always going to need a self model
a model of the cognitive architecture in
which the self model is
embedded it needs to understand the
directly adjacent
computations which are integrated into
it but it seems like the views of
identity
go beyond just this self model
is that the solution to identity what
does open closed or empty individualism
have to say about something like that
open empty and close as ontological
claims
yeah i mean they they're separable from
the functional uses of
a self model it does however have like
bearings
on basically the decision theoretic
rationality
of an intelligence because when it comes
to planning ahead
if you have the intense let's say
objective
of being as happy as you can and
somebody offers you
a cloning machine and they say like hey
you can
trade one year of your life for just a
completely new copy of yourself
do you press the button to make that
happen for making that decision you
actually do require
a model of ontological notion of
identity
unless you just care about replication
so i think that the problem there is
that identity
at least in us apes is caught up in
ethics if you could have an agent like
that where identity was not factored
into ethics then i think that it would
make
a better decision it's definitely a
question too like whether you can
bootstrap
an impartial god's eye view on the
well-being of all sentient beings
without
first having developed a sense of own
identity and then wanting to preserve it
and finally kind of updating it with
more information you know philosophy
reasoning
physics i do wonder if you can start out
without caring about identity and
finally concluding with kind of an
impartial god's eye view i think
probably in practice a lot of those
transitions do happen because a person
is
first concerned with themselves and then
they update the model of who they are
based on more evidence you know i could
be wrong
it might be possible to completely
sidestep kind of darwinian identities
and just
jump straight up into impartial care for
all sentient beings
i don't know so we're getting into the
ethics of identity here and like
why it matters the question for this
portion of the discussion
is what are the ethical implications of
different views
on identity andre so i think
you can sort of kick this conversation
off by talking a little bit about the
game theory
right well yeah the game theory is
surprisingly complicated
just consider within an even person in
fact the different quote-unquote
sub-agents
of an individual let's say you're
drinking with your friends on a friday
evening
but you know you have to wake up early
at 8 am for whatever reason
and you're deciding whether to have
another drink or not
your intoxicated self says yes of course
tonight is all that matters you know
whereas your conscious self might try to
uh
persuade you that no you will also exist
tomorrow in the morning
within a given person there's all kinds
of complex
game theory that happens between
alternative views of identity
even implicitly it becomes obviously
much more tricky when you expand it uh
outwards how like some social movements
in a sense are trying to hack people's
view of identity whether the unit is
your
political party or the country or the
whole ecosystem or whatever it
may be a key thing to consider here
is the existence of legible shelling
points
also called focal points which is in the
absence of communication between
entities
what are some kind of guiding principles
that they can use in order to
effectively coordinate and move towards
a certain goal
i would say that having something like
open individualism
itself can be a powerful selling point
for
coordination especially because if you
can't be convinced
that somebody is an open individualist
you have reasons to trust them there's
all of this
research and how high trust social
environments
are so much more conducive to
productivity and long-term
sustainability than low trust
environments and
expansive notions of identity are very
trust building
on the other hand from a game
theoretical point of view you also have
the problem of
defection within an open individualist
society you have a small
group of people who can fake the test
of open individualism they can take over
from within and instantiate some kind of
a
dictatorship or some type of a close
individualist takeover
of what was a really good society good
for everybody
this is a serious problem even when it
comes to for example
forming groups of people with all of
them share a certain experience
for example mdma or 5mu dmt
or let's say deep stages of meditation
even then you've got to be careful
because people who are resistant
to those states may pretend
that they have an expanded notion of
identity but actually
covertly work towards a much more
reduced sense of identity i've yet to
see
a credible game theoretically aware
solution to how to make this work
if you could clarify the knobs in a
person
whether it be altruism or selfishness
or other things that the different views
on identity
turn and if you clarify how that affects
the game theory then i think that that
would be helpful
i mean i think the biggest nub is
fundamentally
what experiences count from the point of
view
of the fact that you you expect to in a
sense be there
or expect them to be real in as real of
a way as your current experience
is it's also contingent on theories of
consciousness
because you could be an open
individualist and still believe
that higher order cognition is necessary
for consciousness and that
non-human animals are not conscious that
gives rise to all sorts of other
problems
the person presumably is altruistic and
cares about others but they just
still don't include non-human animals
for a completely different reason
in that case definitely another knob is
how you consider what you will be in the
future
whether you consider that to be part of
the universe
or the entirety of the universe
i guess i used to think that personal
identity was
very tied to a hedonic tone
i think of them as like much more
dissociated now there is the general
pattern
people who are very low mood may have
kind of a
bias towards empty individualism people
who
become open individualists often
experience
a huge surge in positive feelings for a
while because they feel that they're
never going to die
like the fear of death greatly
diminishes but i don't actually think
it's a sure fire
or foolproof way of increasing
well-being because
you take seriously open individualism it
also comes with terrible implications
like that hey we are also the pigs in
factory farms
it's not a very pleasant view yeah i
take that seriously
i used to believe for a while the best
thing we could possibly do in the world
was to just write a lot of essays and
books
about why open individualism is true now
i think it's
important to combine it with
consciousness technologies
so that hey once we do want to upgrade
our sense of identity to a greater
circle of compassion that we also have
the
enhanced happiness and mental stability
to be able to actually engage with that
without going crazy
this has me thinking about one point
that i think is very motivating for me
for
the ethical case of veganism take the
common sense normal consciousness like
most people have
and that i have you just feel like a
self that's having an experience
you just feel like you are fortunate
enough to be born as you and to be
having the
andres experience or the lucas
experience and that your life is
from birth to death or whatever and like
when you die you will be annihilated
you will no longer have experience then
who is it that is experiencing the cow
consciousness
like who is it that is experiencing the
chicken and the pig consciousness
there's so many instantiations of that
like billions even if this is based off
of irrationality
it still feels motivating to me yeah i
could just die and wake up
as a cow 10 billion times that's kind of
the experience that is going on right
now
sudden confused awakening into cow
consciousness plus
factory farming conditions i'm not sure
if you find that completely irrational
or motivating or what
no i mean i think it makes sense we have
a common friend as well
magnus binding he wrote a pro-veganism
book
actually kind of with this line of
reasoning it's called you are them
about yeah how a post-theoretical
science of consciousness and
an identity itself is a strong case for
ethical
lifestyle so just touching here on the
ethical implications like some other
points i just want to add here
are the when one is identified with
one's
phenomenal identity in particular i want
to talk about the experience of self
where you feel like
you're a closed individualist which your
life is like when you were born and then
up until when you die that's you
i think that that breeds a very strong
duality
in terms of your relationship your own
personal phenomenal consciousness
the suffering and joy which you have
direct access to
are categorized as mine or not mine
those which are mine
take high moral and ethical priority
over the suffering of others
you're not mind-melded with all of the
other brains right so there's an
epistemological limitation there where
you're not directly experiencing the
suffering of other people but the closed
individualist view
goes a step further and isn't just
saying that there's an epistemological
limitation but it's also
saying that this consciousness is mine
and that consciousness is yours and this
is the distinction between self and
other
and given selfishness that
self-consciousness will take moral
priority over other consciousness
that i think just obviously has massive
ethical implications with regards to
their greed of people
i view here the ethical implications as
being important because
at least in the way that human beings
function if one is able to fully rid
themselves of the ultimate
identification with your personal
consciousness
as being the content of self then i can
move beyond the duality of consciousness
to self another and care about all
instances of well-being and suffering
much more equally than i currently do
that to me seems harder to do at least
with human brains
if we have a strong reification and
identification with
your instances of suffering or
well-being as your own
part of the problem is that the
existence of other subjects of
experiences metaphysical speculation
it's metaphysical speculation that one
should take
extremely seriously i'm not a solipsist
i believe
that other subjects experienced human
and non-human are as
real as mine but nonetheless it is still
speculative
and theoretical one cannot feel their
experiences
there is simply no way given the way
that we are constituted the way
we are that one can behave in an
impartial sort of god-like
with impartial god-like benevolence
i guess i would question perhaps a
little bit that we only care about our
future suffering
within our own experience because this
is me this is mine
it's another in a sense i think we care
about those more
largely because they're more intense you
do
see examples for example mirror touch
synesthesia
of people who if they see somebody else
get hurt
they also experience pain and i don't
mean a fleeting sense of discomfort but
like perhaps even
actual you know strong pain because
they're able to kind of reflect that for
whatever reason
people like that are generally very
motivated to help others as well
and in a sense their implicit self model
includes others or at least weights
others
more than most people do i mean in some
sense you can perhaps
make sense of selfishness in this
context as the coincidence that what is
within our self model is experienced as
more intense
but there's plenty of counter examples
to that including
sense of depersonalization or ego death
where you could experience
the feeling of god for example as being
this eternal and
impersonal force that is infinitely more
intense than you
and therefore it matters more even
though you don't experience it as you
perhaps the core issue is what gets the
the highest amount of intensity
within your world simulation okay so
i also just want to touch on a little
bit about preferences here before we
move on to
how this is relevant to ai alignment and
the creation of beneficial ai
from the moral realist perspective if
you take the metaphysical existence of
consciousness very substantially and you
view it as the ground
of morality then different views on
identity
will shift how you weight the
preferences of other
creatures and so from a moral
perspective
whatever kinds of views of identity end
up broadening your moral circle of
compassion
closer and closer to the end goal of
impartial benevolence for all sentient
beings
according to their degree and kinds of
worth i would view as
a good thing but now there's this other
way to think about identity because if
you're listening to this and you're a
moral anti-realist
there is just the arbitrary evolutionary
and historical set of preferences that
exist across all creatures on the planet
then the views on identity i think are
also obviously again going to
weigh into your moral considerations
about how much to just respect different
preferences right
one might want to go beyond hedonic
consequentialism here
and could just be a preference
consequentialist you could be a
deontological ethicist or a virtue
ethicist too
we could also consider about how
different views on identity
as lived experiences would affect what
it means to become virtuous
if being virtuous means moving beyond
the self actually
i think i understand what you're getting
at i mean really there's kind of two
components to
ontology one is what exists
and then the other one is what is
valuable
you can arrive at something like open
individualism just from the point of
view of
what exists but still have disagreements
with other open individualists about
what is valuable alternatively you could
agree
on what is valuable with somebody but
completely disagree on what exists
to get the power of cooperation
of open individualism as a selling point
there also needs to be some level of
agreement
on what is valuable not just what exists
it definitely sounds arrogant but i do
think that
by the same principle by which you
arrive at open individualism or empty
individualism
basically non-standard views of
identities you can also
arrive at hedonistic utilitarianism and
that is
again like the principle of really
caring about knowing
who or what you are fundamentally to
know yourself more deeply
also entails understanding from second
to second how
your preferences impact your state of
consciousness
it is my view that just as open
individualism
you can think of it as the implication
of taking a very systematic approach
to make sense of identity likewise
philosophical hedonism
is also an implication of taking a very
systematic approach
at trying to figure out what is valuable
how do we know that pleasure is good
yeah i mean does the pleasure pain
access disclose the world's
intrinsic metric of dis value there is
something completely coercive
about pleasure and pain and one can't
transcend the
pleasure pain axis taking heroin or
enhanced interrogation there is no one
with an inverted pleasure pain axis
supposed counter examples like cedar
massacres
in fact just validate the primacy of the
pressure plane axis
what follows from the primacy of the
pleasure pane access should we be aiming
as classical
utilitarian surge to maximize the
positive abundance of
subjective value and the universe or at
least our forward light cone
but if we are classical utilitarians
there is this
latently apocalyptic implication of
classical
utilitarianism that we ought to be
aiming to launch something like a
utilitronium or hedonium shockwave where
eutenetronium or hedonium is
matter and energy optimized for pure
bliss
and so rather than any kind of notion of
personal identity as we currently
understand it if one is a classical
utilitarian
or if one is programming a computer or a
robot for the utility function of
classical utilitarianism
should essentially one be uh aiming
therefore to launch
an apocalyptic utilitronium shockwave
or alternatively should one be trying to
ensure
that the abundance of positive value
within our cosmological horizon is
sub-optimal by utilitarian criteria
i don't actually personally advocate
you to the tronium shockwave i don't
think it's sociologically
realistic i think much more
sociologically realistic
is to aim for world based on gradients
of intelligent bliss
because that way people's existing
values and preferences for the most part
can be conserved but nonetheless if one
is
a classical utilitarian it's not clear
what is allowed this kind of
messy compromise all right so
now that we're getting into the juicy
hedonistic comparative type stuff
let's talk about here about how this is
relevant to ai alignment
and the creation of beneficial ai i
think that this is clear based off of
the conversations we've had already
about the ethical implications
and just how prevalent identity is in
our world
for the functioning of society and
sociology
just civilization in general so
let's limit the conversation for the
moment just to ai alignment
and for this initial discussion of ai
alignment i just want to limit it to the
definition
of ai alignment as developing the
technical process
by which ais can learn human preferences
and help further express and idealize
humanity so exploring how identity
is important and meaningful for that
process two points i think that it's
relevant for
who are we making the ai for different
views on identity i think would matter
because if we assume that sufficiently
powerful and integrated
ai systems are likely to have
consciousness or to have qualia
they're moral agents in themselves so
who are we making the ai for
we're making new patients or subjects of
morality if we
ground morality on consciousness so from
a purely egoistic
point of view the ai alignment process
is just for humans it's just
to get the ai to serve us but if we care
about all sentient beings impartially
and we just want to maximize
conscious bliss in the world and we
don't have these dualistic distinction
of consciousness being self or other we
could make the ai
alignment process something that is more
purely altruistic
that we recognize that we're creating
something that is
fundamentally more morally relevant than
we are
given that it may have more profound
capacities for
experience or not and david i'm also
holding in my hand
i know that you're skeptical of the
ability of agi or super intelligence to
be conscious
i agree that that's not solved yet but
i'm just working here with the idea
okay maybe if they are so i think it can
change the altruism versus selfishness
motivations around who we're training
the ais for and then the second part
is why are we making the ai are we
making it for ourselves are we making it
for the world
if we take a view from nowhere what
andres called a god's eye view
is this ultimately something that is for
humanity or is it something ultimately
for just making
a better world personally
i feel that if the end goal is ultimate
loving kindness
and impartial ethical commitment to the
well-being of all sentient creatures in
all directions
then ideally the process is something
that we're doing like for the world and
that we recognize the intrinsic moral
worth
of the agi and super intelligence as
ultimately more morally relevant
descendants of ours
so i wonder if you guys have any
reactions to this uh yeah definitely
so many tongue-in-cheek but uh you just
made me chuckle when you said why are we
making the ai
to begin with i think there's a case to
be made that the actual reason why we're
making
ai is as a kind of a impressive display
of fitness
in order to signal our intellectual
fortitude and
superiority i mean sociologically
speaking you know like
actually you know getting an ai to do
something really well
it's a way in which you can yourself
signal your own intelligence and
i guess i worry to some extent that this
is a bit of a tragedy of the comments
as it is the case with a weapon
development you're so concerned with
whether you can
and especially because the social
incentives that you're going to gain
status
and be looked at as somebody who's
really competent and smart
that you don't really stop and wonder
whether you should be building this in
the first place leaving that aside just
from a purely
ethically motivated point of view i do
remember
thinking and having a lot of discussions
many years ago
about if we can make a super computer
experience
what it's like for a human to be on mdma
then all of a sudden that supercomputer
becomes a moral patient
it actually matters you probably
shouldn't turn it off
maybe in fact you should make more of
them a very important thing
i'd like to say here is i think it's
really important to distinguish the
notion of intelligence
on the one hand as causal power over
your environment
and on the other hand as the capacity
for
self insight and introspection and
understanding reality
and i would say that we tend to confuse
this quite a bit
i mean especially in circles that don't
take consciousness very seriously
it's usually implicitly assumed that
having a
superhuman ability to control your
environment
entails that you also have in a sense
kind of a superhuman
sense of self or a superhuman broad
sense of intelligence
whereas even if you are a functionalist
i mean even if you
believe that a digital computer can be
conscious you can make it a pretty
strong case
that even then it is not something
automatic it's not just that
if you program the appropriate behavior
it will automatically also be conscious
a super straightforward example here is
that if you have the chinese room
if it's just a giant lookup table
clearly
is not a subject of experience even
though the input output mapping
might be very persuasive there's
definitely still problems there and i
think like if we
aim instead towards maximizing
intelligence in the broad sense
that does entail also
the ability to actually understand the
nature
and scope of other states of
consciousness and in that sense i think
a super intelligence of that sort
would be intrinsically aligned with the
intrinsic values of consciousness
but there's just so many ways of making
partial super intelligences
that maybe are super intelligent in many
ways but not in that one in particular
and i worry about that i sometimes give
this kind of simplistic
trichotomy three conceptions of super
intelligence
one there's the kind of intelligence
explosion
recursively self-improving
software-based ai
then there is the kurzweil scenario
complete
fusion of humans and our machines and
then there is
what very crudely one can call
biological super intelligence
but not just rewriting our genetic
source code but also
the neural link here is prefiguring it
essentially
narrow super intelligence on a chip so
that anything
that a digital computer can do that a
human or a transhuman can do and so
yes i see a full spectrum super
intelligence as a
biological descendants super sentient
able to navigate
radically alien states of consciousness
and so i think is it the question that
you're asking why
are we developing narrow ai
possibly narrow agi is that question the
purely non-biological machine attempt at
super intelligence i'm speaking
specifically from the ai alignment
perspective how you align current day
systems and future systems
to superintelligence and beyond with
human values and preferences
and so when the question born of that in
the context of these questions of
identity is who are we making that ai
for and like why are we making the ai
if you've got buddha i teach one thing
and one thing only suffering in the end
of suffering
buddha would press the off button i
would press the off button
what's the off button sorry the notional
you know initiator
a vacuum phase transition or something
and obliterate
darwinian life but when people talk
about ai alignment
most people working in the field they
are not talking about
a buddhist ethic they have something
else in mind
and in practical terms this is not a
fruitful line
you know they're kind of buddhist
benetarian negative utilitarian
suffering focused ethics
essentially that one wants to be kind of
ratcheting up hedonic range he don't
accept points in the way that you're
conserving people's
existing preferences even though their
existing preferences and values are in
many cases in conflict with each other
now how on actually implements this in
a classical digital computer or a
classical connectionist system or some
kind of hybrid
i don't know precisely at least the one
pretty famous cognitive scientist and ai
theorist
does propose the the buddhist ethic of
turning the
off button of the universe thomas
metzinger and his benevolent artificial
anti-natalism i mean yeah actually
that's pretty interesting because
he explores you know the idea of an ai
that truly
kind of extrapolates human values and
and what's good for us as subject of
experience and the ai concludes what we
are
psychologically unable to which is that
the ethical choice is non-existence
but yeah i mean i think like that's as
david pointed out implausible
i think it's much better to put our
efforts
in creating a super cooperator cluster
that tries to recalibrate the hedonic
set point so that we are animated by
gradients of please
sociological constraints are really
really important here
otherwise eures being irrelevant being
irrelevant yeah is one thing
the other thing is unleashing an
ineffective or failed
attempt at sterilizing the world which
would be so much much worse
i don't agree with this view david
generally i think that darwinian history
has probably been net negative
but i'm extremely optimistic about how
good the future can be
and so i think it's an open question at
the end of time how much
misery and suffering and positive
experience there was
so i guess i would say i'm agnostic as
to this question
but if we get ai alignment right and
these other things then i think that it
can be extremely good
and i just want to tether this back to
identity and ai alignment
i do have the strong intuition that if
empty individualism
is correct at an ontological level then
actually negative utilitarianism can be
pretty strongly defended
on the grounds that when you have a
moment of intense
suffering that's the entirety of that
entity's existence
and especially with eternalism once it
happened there's nothing you can do to
prevent it there's something that seems
particularly
awful about allowing inherently negative
experiences to just
exist that said i think like open
individualism actually
may to some extent weaken that because
even if the suffering was very intense
you can still
imagine that if you identify with
consciousness as a whole
you may be willing to undergo some bad
suffering
as a trade-off for something much much
better in the future
it sounds completely insane if you're
currently experiencing a cluster
headache or something
astronomically painful but maybe from
the point of view of
eternity it actually makes sense those
are still
tiny specks of experience relative to
the bliss
that is going to exist in the future you
can imagine jupiter brains and
dyson spheres just in a constant
ecstatic state
so i think open individualism might
counterbalance some of the
negative utilitarian worries and would
be something that a
ai would have to contemplate and might
push it one way or the other
so let's go ahead and expand the
definition of ai alignment
a broader way we can look at the ai
alignment problem or the problem of
generating beneficial ai
and making future ai stuff go well where
that is understood as the project of
making sure that the technical political
social and moral consequences of
short-term to superintelligence and
beyond
is that like as we go through all of
that that is a beneficial process
thinking about identity in that process
we were talking about how strong
nationalism or strong identity
or identification with regards to a
nation-state is a form of
identity construction that people do the
nation or the country becomes part of
self
one of the problems of the ai alignment
problem is arms racing
between countries and so taking
shortcuts on safety
i'm not trying to propose clear answers
or solutions here
it's unclear how successful an
intervention here could
even be but these views on identity and
how much nationalism shifts or not i
think
feed into how difficult or not the
problem will be
the point of game theory becomes very
very important in that
yes you do want to help other people who
are also
trying to improve the well-being of all
consciousness
on the other hand um if there is a way
to fake
caring about the entirety of
consciousness that is a problem
because then you would be using
resources on people who would hoard them
or even worse
wrestle the power away from you so that
they can focus on their narrow sense of
identity
in that sense i think having
technologies in order to
set particular phenomenal experiences of
identity
as well as to be able to detect them
might be super important
but above all and i mean this is
definitely my area of research
having a way of objectively quantifying
how good or bad a state of consciousness
is based on the activity of a nervous
system
seems to me like an extraordinarily key
component
for any kind of a serious ai alignment
if you're actually trying to prevent bad
scenarios in the future you've got to
have a principal way
of knowing whether the outcome is bad or
at the very
least knowing whether the outcome is
terrible the
aligned ai should be able to grasp that
a certain state of consciousness
even if nobody has experienced it before
will be really bad
and it should be avoided that tends to
be the lens through which i
see this in terms of improving people's
internal self-consistency as david
pointed out i think it's kind of
pointless to try to satisfy a lot of
people's preferences
such as having their favorite sports
team
win because there's really just no way
of satisfying everybody's preferences
in the realm of psychology is where a
lot of these interventions would happen
you can't expect an ai to be aligned
with you if you
yourself are not aligned with yourself
right if you have
all these strange psychotic competing
sub agents
so it seems like part of the process is
going to be developing techniques to
become more consistent so that we can
actually be
helped in terms of
risks this century i mean nationalism
has been responsible for most of the
wars of the past two centuries and
nationalism is
highly likely to lead to catastrophic
war this
century and the underlying global
catastrophic risk
i don't think is ai it's male human
primates
doing what male human primates do is
designed by evolution
to fight compete to wage war and even
vegan pacifists like me how do we spend
our leisure
time playing violent video games i mean
there are
technical ways one can envisage
mitigating the risk
i mean it's perhaps unduly optimistic
aiming for all
female governance or aiming for uh
democratically
accountable world state and the auspices
of the united nations but i think
unless one actually does have somebody
with a monopoly on the use of
force that essentially we are going to
have cataclysmic
nuclear war this century it's highly
likely i think we're sleepwalking our
way towards
disaster that it's more intellectually
exciting and interesting discussing
exotic risk you know from ai it goes
fume or something like that but there is
much more
mundane catastrophes that i suspect are
going to unfold the century
all right so getting into this other
part here about
ai alignment and beneficial ai
throughout this next century
there's a lot of different things that
increased intelligence and capacity and
power
over the world is going to enable
there's going to be
human biological species divergence via
ai enabled bioengineering there is this
fundamental desire for immortality in
many people
and the drive towards super intelligence
and beyond for some people
promises immortality i think that in
terms of closed individualism here
closed individualism is extremely
motivating for this extreme self-concern
and desire for immortality
there are people currently today who are
investing in say like cryonics
because they want to freeze themselves
and make it long enough so that they can
somehow become immortal very clearly
influenced by
their ideas of identity
as you all know harare was saying on our
last podcast it subverts many
of the classic liberal myths that we
have about
the same intrinsic worth across all
people
and then if you add humans 2.0 or 3.0 or
4.0 into the mixture it's going to
subvert that even more
so there are important questions of
identity there i think
with sufficiently advanced super
intelligence people
flirt with the idea of being uploaded
the identity questions here which are
relevant are
if we scan the information architecture
the neural architecture of your brain
and upload it
will people feel like that is them is it
not them what does it mean to be you
also of course in scenarios where people
want to merge with the ai
what is it that you would want to be
kept in the merging process
what is superfluous to you what is not
non-essential to your identity or what
it means to be you that you would be
okay or not with merging and then i
think that most importantly here
i'm very interested in the descendants
scenario where we just view ai
as like our evolutionary descendants
there's this tendency in humanity to not
be okay with this descendants scenario
because of closed individualist views on
identity
they won't see that consciousness is the
same kind of thing or they won't see it
as their own consciousness
they see that well-being like through
the lens of self another so that makes
people look less interested and they're
being
descendant super intelligent conscious
ai's maybe there's also a bit of
speciesism
in there i wonder if you guys want to
have any reactions to
identity in any of these processes again
they are human biological species
divergence via ai enabled
bioengineering immortality uploads
merging or the descendants scenario
in spite of thinking that darwinian life
is sentient malware i think clinic
should be opt out and
cryothenazia should be opt in as a way
to
defang death and so long as
someone is suspended in optimal
conditions it ought to be possible for
advanced intelligence to
reanimate that person and sure if one is
an
empty individualist or you're the kind
of person who wakes up in the morning
trouble that you're not the kind of the
person who went to sleep last night this
may not really be you
but if you're more normal yes i think it
should be possible to
reanimate you if you are suspended
in terms of mind uploads this is
back to the binding problem even
assuming that
you can be scanned with a moderate
degree of fidelity i
don't think your notional digital
counterpart
is subject to experience even if i am
completely
wrong here and that somehow subjects of
experience
inexplicably emerge in classical digital
computers there's no
guarantee that the qualia would be the
same
after all you can replay a game of chess
with perfect fidelity but there's no
guarantee
incidentals like the textures of the
pieces will be the same why expect the
textures of qualia to be the same but
that isn't really my objection it's the
fact that
a digital computer cannot support
phenomenally bound subjects of
experience
i also think cryonics is really good
even though with a different
non-standard view of personal identity
it's kind of like puzzling like why
would you care about it
lots of practical considerations i like
what they've
said of like defanging death i think
that's a good idea but also
giving people skin in the game for the
future
you know people who enact policy and
become you know politically successful
often tend to be 50 years plus and
there's a lot of things that they wait
on that they will not actually get to
experience
that probably biases politicians and
people enacting policy
to focus especially just on short-term
gains as opposed to really
generally trying to improve the long
term and i think cryonics would be
helpful
in giving people skin in the game more
broadly speaking
it does seem to be the case that what
aspect of transhumanism
a person is likely to focus on depends a
lot on their theories of identity
i mean if we break down transhumanism
into the three supers
of super happiness super longevity and
super intelligence
the longevity branch is pretty large
there's a lot of people
looking for ways of rejuvenating
preventing aging
and reviving ourselves or even uploading
ourselves
then there's people who are very
interested in super intelligence
i think that's probably the most popular
type of transhumanism
nowadays that one i think does rely to
some extent on people having
a functionalist information theoretic
account
of their own identity you know there's
all of these tropes of hey if you leave
a large enough digital
footprint online super intelligence will
be able to reverse
engineer your brain just from that and
maybe like reanimate you in the future
or something of that nature and then
there's yeah people like david and i
and qualia research institute as well
that care
primarily about super happiness we think
of it as kind of a
requirement for a future that is
actually worth living
you can have all the longevity and all
the intelligence you want but if you're
not happy
i don't i don't really see the point a
lot of the concerns with longevity fear
of death and so on
in retrospect i think will be probably
considered some kind of a
neurosis you know obviously a
genetically adaptive neurosis but
something that can be cured with mood
enhancing technologies
leveraging human selfishness or
leveraging how most people are closed
individualists
seems like the way to having good ai
alignment
to one extent i find the immortality
pursuits through cryonics to be pretty
elitist
but i think it's a really good point
that giving the policymakers and the
older generation and people
empower more skin in the game over the
future
is both potentially very good and also
very scary
it's very scary to the extent to which
they could get absolute power
but also very good if you're able to
mitigate risks of them developing
absolute power
but again as you said it motivates them
towards more deeply and profoundly
considering future considerations
being less myopic being less selfish so
that
getting the ai alignment process right
and doing the necessary technical work
it's not done for a short-term
nationalistic game
again with an asterisk here that the
risk is unilaterally getting more and
more power
yeah yeah yeah also without cryonics
another way
to increase skin in the game maybe more
straightforwardly positive
bliss technologies do that a lot of
people who are depressed or
nihilistic or vengeful or misanthropic
they don't really care about destroying
the world or watching it burn
so to speak because they don't have
anything to lose but if you have a
really reliable
mdma-like technological device that
reliably produces wonderful states of
consciousness i think people will be
much more careful about preserving their
own health but
and also not watch the world burn
because they know i could be back home
and actually experiencing this rather
than
just trying to satisfy my misanthropic
desires
yeah so the happiest people i know work
in the field of
existential risk and rather than
great happiness making people reckless
it can also make them
more inclined to conserve and protect
awesome i guess just one more thing that
i wanted to hit on these different
ways that technology is going to change
society is
i don't know in my heart the ideal is
the vow
to liberate all sentient beings in all
directions from suffering
the closed individual's view seems
generally fairly antithetical to that
but there's also this desire for me to
be realistic about leveraging that
human selfishness towards that ethic
the capacity here for conversations on
identity going forward
if we can at least give people more
information to subvert or challenge or
give them information about why the
common sense closed individualist view
might be wrong
i think it would just have a ton of
implications for how people end up
viewing
human species divergence or immortality
or uploads or merging or the descendants
scenario
in max's book life 3.0 he describes a
bunch of different scenarios for
how you want the world to be as the
impact of ai grows
if we're lucky enough to reach super
intelligent ai
these scenarios that he gives are for
example
in egalitarian utopia where humans
cyborgs and uploads coexist
peacefully thanks to property abolition
and guaranteed income
there's a libertarian utopia where human
cyborgs and uploads and super
intelligences
coexist peacefully thanks to property
rights there is a protector god scenario
where essentially omniscient and
omnipotent ai maximizes human happiness
by intervening
only in ways that preserve our feeling
of control of our own destiny and hides
well enough that many humans even doubt
the ai's existence
there's enslaved god which is kind of
self-evident the ai is a slave to our
will
a descendant scenario which i described
earlier where ai's replace human beings
but give us a graceful exit making us
view them as our worthy descendants much
as parents feel happy and proud to have
a child who's smarter than them
who learns from them and then
accomplishes what they could only dream
of
even if they can't live to see it so
after the book was released
max did a survey of which ideal
societies people were most excited about
and basically most people wanted either
the egalitarian utopia
or the libertarian utopia
these are very human-centric of course
because i think most people are closed
individualists so like okay they're
gonna pick that
and then they wanted a protector god
next and then the fourth most popular
was an enslaved god
the fifth most popular was descendants
i'm a very
big fan of the descendants scenario
maybe it's because of my empty
individualism
i just feel here that as views on
identity
are like quite uninformed for most
people most people don't take it or
closed individualism just seems
intuitively true from the beginning
because it seems like
it's been selected for mostly by
darwinian evolution to have a very
strong sense of self
i just think that challenging
conventional views on identity will very
much shift
the kinds of worlds that people are okay
with or the kinds of worlds that people
want
like if we had like a massive public
education campaign about the philosophy
of identity
and then take the same survey later i
think that the numbers would be
much more different that seems to be
like a necessary part of the education
of humanity
in the process of beneficial ai and ai
alignment
to me the descendants scenario just
seems best because it's
more clearly in line with this ethic of
being impartially devoted to maximizing
the well-being of sentience
everywhere i'm curious to know your guys
reaction to these different scenarios
about how you feel views on identity as
they shift will
inform the kinds of worlds that humanity
finds beautiful or meaningful or like
worthy of pursuit through and with ai
starting with the most obvious that i
focus on if today's
hedonic range is minus ten to zero to
plus ten
yes building a civilization with a
hedonic range of plus 70 to plus 100
by once more contrast or plus 90 to a
plus 100
the multiple phase changes and
consciousness involved there are just
completely
inconceivable to humans but in terms of
full spectrum
super intelligence what we don't know is
the
radically alien state spaces of
consciousness
i mean far more different than let's say
dreaming consciousness and awakening
consciousness
that i suspect that we are going to
explore and we countlessly we just do
not have the language
or the concepts to conceptualize what
these alien state spaces are like i
suspect
millions billions of years of
exploration lie ahead
i assume that a central element will be
the pleasure axis that they will be
generically wonderful
but they will be completely alien and so
talk of
identity with primitive darwinian
malware like us
is quite fanciful consider the following
thought experiment where you have a
chimpanzee right next to
a person who is right next to another
person
where the third one is currently on a
high dose of dmt
combined with ketamine and salvia
if you consider those three entities i
think very likely
actually the experience of the
chimpanzee and the experience of the
sober person
are very much alike compared to the
person who's on
dmt ketamine salvia who is in a
completely different alien state space
of consciousness and
in some sense biologically unrelatable
from the point of view of the qualia
and the sense of self and time and space
and all of those things so
personally i think having intimations
with alien state spaces of consciousness
is
actually also quite apart from like
changes in a
feeling that you become one with the
universe merely
having experience with like really
different states of consciousness
makes it easier for you to identify with
consciousness as a whole
you realize okay like my dmt self so to
speak
cannot exist naturally and it's just
like so much different
to who i am normally and even more
different than perhaps being a
chimpanzee
that you could imagine caring as well
about like alien states spaces of
consciousness that are
completely non-human and i think that it
can be pretty helpful
the other reason why i give a lot of
credence to
open individualism being a winning
strategy
even just from a purely political and
sociological point of view
is that open individualists are not
afraid
of changing their own state of
consciousness because they
realize that it will be them either way
whereas closed individuals can actually
be pretty scared
of for example taking dmt or something
like that
they tend to have at least the suspicion
that oh my gosh
is the person who's going to be on dmt
me
am i going to be there or maybe i'm just
being possessed by a different entity
with completely different
values and consciousness no matter what
type of consciousness your brain
generates
it's going to be you it massively
amplifies the
degrees of freedom for coordination plus
you're not afraid of tuning your
consciousness for particular
new computational uses again this could
be extremely powerful as a cooperation
and coordination tool
to summarize i think a plausible and
very nice future scenario is going to be
the mixture of open individualism
on the one hand second generically
enhanced hedonic tone so everything is
amazing
and third expanded range of possible
experiences
that we will have the tools to
experience pretty much arbitrary state
spaces of consciousness and
consider them our own the descendant
scenario i think it's much easier to
imagine
thinking of the new entities as your
offspring
if you can at least know what they feel
like you know you can take a drug or
something and know okay this is
what it's like to be a post-human
android i like it
this is wonderful it's better than being
a human that would make it possible
wonderful so this last question is just
the role of identity in the ai
itself or the super intelligence itself
as it experiences the world
the ethical implications of those
identity models etc
there is the question of identity now
and if we get aligned super intelligence
and post
human superintelligence and we have
jupiter brains or dyson spheres or
whatever
there's a question of identity evolving
in that system
we are very much creating life 3.0 and
there is a substantive question of what
kind of identity
views it will take what its phenomenal
experience of self or not will have
this all is relevant and important
because if we're
concerned with maximizing conscious
well-being these are flavors of
consciousness
which would require a sufficiently
rigorous science of consciousness to
understand their
valence properties i mean i think it's a
really
really good thing to think about the
overall frame
i tend to utilize to analyze these kind
of questions
is i wrote an article you can find it in
quality computing that it's called
consciousness versus replicators i think
that is a
pretty good overarching ethical
framework where basically
i describe how different kinds of ethics
can give different worldviews
but also they depend on your
philosophical sophistication
the very beginning you have like ethics
such as the battle between good and evil
but then you start introspecting like
okay what is evil exactly
and you realize that nobody sets out to
do evil from the very beginning usually
they actually have motivations that make
sense
within their own experience then you
shift towards this other theory
that's called the balance between good
and evil super common
in eastern religions also people who
take a lot of psychedelics or meditate a
lot
tend to arrive to that view as in like
oh don't be too concerned about
suffering or the universe
it's all a huge yin and yang the evil
part
makes the good power better or like
weird things like that
then you have a little bit more
developed what i call gradients of
wisdom
i would say like sam harris and
definitely a lot of people in our
community think that way which is they
come to the realization that
you know there are societies that don't
help human flourishing
and there are you know ideologies that
do and it's really important to be
discerning
we can't just say hey everything is
equally good
but finally i would say the fourth level
would be consciousness versus
replicators
which involves one taking
open individualism seriously and second
realizing that
anything that matters it matters because
it influences experiences
if you have that as your underlying
ethical principle
there's like this danger of replicators
hijacking
our motivational architecture in order
to pursue their own
replication independent of the
well-being of sentience and you guard
for that
i think you're in a pretty good space to
actually do a lot of good
i would say perhaps that is the sort of
ethics or morality we should
think about how to instantiate you know
artificial intelligence
in the extreme you have what i call a
pure
replicator and a pure replicator
essentially is a
system or an entity that uses all of its
resources
exclusively to make copies of itself
independently
of whether that causes good or bad
experiences elsewhere it just doesn't
care
i would argue that humans are not pure
replicators
that in fact we do care about
consciousness
at the very least our own consciousness
and evolution
is recruiting the fact that we care
about consciousness in order to
as a side effect increase our inclusive
fitness of our genes
but these discussions we're having right
now the possibility of post-human ethic
is
the genie is getting out of the bottle
in the sense of consciousness
is kind of taking its own values and
trying to transcend
the selfish genetic process that gave
rise to it
ooh i like that that's good anything to
add david
no i simply uh hope we have buddhist
ai i agree all right
so i've really enjoyed this conversation
i feel
more confused now than when i came in
which is very good
so yeah thank you both so much for
coming on
if you enjoyed this podcast please
subscribe give it a like or share it on
your preferred social media platform
we'll be back again soon with another
episode in the ai alignment series
you